when you talk about accepting the
outcome of the election
i must tell you senator your party has
spent the last three and a half years
trying to overturn the results of the
last election
it's amazing when joe biden was vice
president of the united states
the fbi actually spied on president
trump and my campaign
i mean there were documents released
this week that the cia actually made a
referral
uh to the fbi documenting that those
allegations were coming from the hillary
clinton campaign and of course
we've all seen the avalanche the what
what you put the country through
for for the better part of three years
until it was founded there was no
obstruction no collusion case closed
and then senator harris you and your
colleagues in the
in the congress tried to impeach the
president of the united states
over a phone call and now hillary
clinton has actually said to joe biden
that under in her words under no
circumstances should he concede the
election
so let me just say i think we're going
to win this election
president trump and i are fighting every
day in courthouses to prevent
joe biden and kamala harris from
changing the rules and creating this
universal mail-in voting that will
create a massive opportunity for voter
fraud
and we have a free and fair election we
know we're going to have confidence in
it
and i believe in all my heart the
president donald trump's going to be
re-elected for four more years
you know
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the show my name is wayne dupree and
we are live
broadcasting from the brickhouse studios
and i my
phone will not charge up i had the same
problem two days ago
i had to get a new charger wires were
completely ruined i guess i don't know
yeah just this wireless charger is not
wireless charging
um okay whatever
okay um last night was the presidential
what was the vice president
vice presidential debate
uh mike pence and kamala harris
uh first off let me introduce you to
miss liabel what's up lee
hey what's up how are you i'm fine
make sure you're sharing the show
everybody shout out please
youtube facebook let me let me um
let me give you a little information on
uh facebook right now
i took care of everything that i had to
with facebook um
about at the beginning of the week uh
they tagged us for a fake story we took
care of that
they didn't fix my audience reach they
put
eight or nine stories back up there that
had already been taken care of
they slapped that on me so that they
wouldn't give me audience reach
[Music]
i argued with my facebook representative
the person who's supposed to be
coordinating conservative voices uh
it slapped it down to two yesterday
morning
as of last night or yesterday afternoon
uh it was down to no facebook no stories
of mine
were labeled fake news none and they
still haven't
returned or gave me my facebook audience
reach back
yeah they definitely didn't because we
had over like 60 000 on periscope
watching and then it was
like 8 000 on facebook and normally
behind the scenes if there's fifty
thousand watching on periscope that
means there's probably a hundred
thousand watching on
facebook and it was eight thousand so
there's a major
major issue going on and and
i mean it let's see facebook man's
marketing firm that paid teens to post
for trump
okay um that just came across just few
minutes ago
again uh leah just said we had about 60
000 that was watching on facebook i mean
um that was watching on periscope
totally and
i want to give a shout out on the
periscope because periscope
thank you has opened up the doors that i
want to hear
uh us talk can watch and thank you
periscope thank you for doing it but
facebook uh you know what honestly
honestly y'all got something up the
crawl man
they're starting to remind me of china
yeah yeah
we're not doing anything to you that's
the thing we're not doing anything to
you
we aren't pushing out fake news we
aren't pushing we are talking about
the election we're talking about the
best way forward
in this election and the people that
want to hear
come to us to listen the people that
don't want to hear
go somewhere else that's the way
democracy is
or or at least that's what you're
supposed to be practicing
but i mean y'all have a little communist
regime over there and
i'm not gonna be quiet about it i'm not
i'm not um
we did the numbers on it uh
they dropped my reach in september
90 what what did bryan say about 95 96
yeah 96 percent they dropped it and i
mean
that's a drastic drop considering two
months before that you were
almost hitting tooth out 200 000 people
a day
if you were a democrat and you were for
joe
i can't imagine they'd probably be
giving you free ads right
yeah yeah yeah so um
what so what did you think about the uh
the
the first part i ain't look what did you
think about the debate overall
overall i was happy to hear substance
from mike pence
i think that there were some questions
that weren't answered by kamala
that was troubling to me um
and i think that she what i saw last
night was
a kamala that has trouble connecting
with people intellectually
emotionally she struggles with trying to
connect with people mike pence does not
and when she tries to connect she knows
she's not good at it
it comes off fake and
it's embarrassing for her you can tell
that she struggles with that
and then you have mike pence who makes
you feel warm and fuzzy when he
talks with the calming demeanor so
overall yeah i think mike want even from
bipartisan looking back at it is just an
opinion
mike won that um and i think that's
important
uh i have a special guest on and
um i call him unk i call him uncle uh he
is uh
he is really been influential over the
past three years
um you know we watched him flourish
uh during the 2016 presidential campaign
and he hasn't shied away from
uh letting you know
what he thinks where we should be going
and what we should be doing he talks to
president trump all the time we go to
the white house
all the time he has the president's ear
present listens to him
uh and he has been instrumental with
talking about opportunity zones getting
that information out
uh uh first step act and
so so many different things meaning he
didn't just sit on the sideline
he got up from the porch and decided to
walk down
and up the street yelling what people
needed to do and how
they should do it and honestly we all
honestly you know i ain't trying to blow
his head up or anything but
he's an example of how people should um
be an activist
in getting out there and doing what
people are supposed to be doing instead
of just
yakking it up on social media um
thinking that
thinking that you're really doing
something and twitter is not even in the
top
eight or nine of top social media
platforms you know
so another great thing about him is he's
also funny too so he captivates you
in more than one way honestly sometimes
you just have to laugh so
he he makes things funny as well and fun
so we appreciate that
let me bring him on right now i'm
talking about pastor darrell scott
what's up man
good man good how about you i'm all
right i'm all right i'm um
i'm trying how's my other friend over
here hey
so excited to have you on when he told
me i was like yes
thank you very much i appreciate that
look tell talk how how how do we get
from last night's debate
to the media trying to make it seem like
mike pence was mansplaining i don't
understand that mansplaining
first of all let me say this and i want
to go on the record
and say this and i mean it i'm going to
say it as professionally
as clearly and succinctly as i possibly
can
okay no joke i'm being dead serious
kamala black hillary harris
sucked last night i need to get that out
the way first
and lay that as a foundation that we can
build upon
hillary was i mean uh hillary clinton
that's awesome that's awesome kamala
harris i thought it was hillary in
blackface for a minute kamala
harris was horrible last night and you
know what
early on i knew that she was getting uh
getting her getting her butt handed to
her in that in the debate
because she resorted to all of the
stereotypical
antics right you know it's if it's a
split screen
it's the head shake it's the um
it's the oh it's the hissy fit it's
all of these old stereotypical black
angry
diary of a mad black woman antics
that she resorted to very very early on
because he was killing her with the
truth
yeah and so she go and you know what hey
i'm sorry
that's a line black woman right there
she lied for the sake of conversation
i mean yeah no i am not against fracking
but here's the tape that says
i will in fracking no i'm not against
fracking no
i'm against fracking no i'm not against
the green new deal no i'm against the
green dude
that's a lion she's in line
so and so and that sucked moderator
that i'm so sick of them moderators
the moderator let her get away with
murder they didn't ask her
one challenging confrontational question
about biden or his policies
it's like every single question is
geared one way directly indirectly
against donald trump
she sucked she got her butt the fly did
better than her
yeah that's all they're talking about
now is the fly i actually saw a meme
today
and the fly had to make america great
again hat on
and i put on i put up a couple of fly
pictures last night on twitter
uh i had to uh i went and found some fly
images
and made me a couple of flying tweets
but when it first came
when it was first on him the first thing
i tweeted was somebody tell kamala to
call her fly
off a pitch
that's great so what do you think of
mike's uh what do you think pence's mic
drop was like what did you like
like what was his best line you think
any specific line that comes to
memory uh he says you can have your
opinion
on opinion but you can't have your own
facts
right then he said uh about biden being
a cheerleader
for china i mean pence was killing her
all night long when you think about it
he was dropping nuke after nuke after
nuke on her
and her response to each one would be i
don't know
that's what was killing me the antics
you know what it was i'm telling you
what it was
she confused the debate stage
with the courtroom and she was trying to
treat
the american public like they were a
jury and she was trying to convince the
jury
of the guilt of her um of whoever it was
she was prosecuting
and you know once again those
prosecutors will resort to lies and have
truths
they'll withhold evidence they'll
conceal evidence whatever they have to
do
to win their case and that's what she
was trying to do she was trying to
prosecute a case last night
and it was it wasn't coming across
because pence was killing her because he
was unflappable
you know getting me i the the first
question out of the box
the first i mean and and you mentioned
moderate but the first question out of
the box
was
covet really has destroyed the nation
and
what it's in in the trump basically
trump administration has
not done what we were supposed to do i'm
like well god i mean
right right off the top and i mean she
didn't hide
this moderator susan susan
yeah didn't hide who she was from the
beginning and
i like how mike pence a couple of times
in there
called out usa today and susan for
their liberal bias too i mean he he did
it on the slide
you had to catch it but he he did it a
couple times
he called her out but i mean most of all
the questions
really was uh a slam on the trump
administration
either it was helping come out or
uh um putting down the trump
administration to pence and making him
defend it
there was no accountability
regarding joe biden kamala harris and by
extension barack obama
at all no accountability
and whenever uh vice president pence
would score
points she would uh endeavor to change
topics or she wouldn't reimp
reinforce or re-emphasize the question
that he asked she let her off the hook
about the green new deal she let her off
the hook about fracking
she let her off the hook you know he
came right back and answered that first
question about covert by saying listen
whatever you see about you guys response
how you will respond to covet
you're simply saying you would do what
we're already doing but joe has a
history of plagiarizing
i'm kind of upset right because the
first debate chris wallace endeavored to
ask
donald trump for the umpteenth time
about white supremacy
why joe biden was not called into
question regarding his record concerning
the black community nor was she calling
the question
about her accusations about joe biden
being a racist and a sexual predator
that was not introduced at all and i was
very disappointed about that
and i wish vice president pence had
introduced it as well
i agree women around the world want to
know why another woman is citing on the
fact that she said
an intern could have been raped by him
women want to know
answers to that why she's okay with that
i agree with you
because she doesn't care about it as
long as she gets a promotion let me tell
you something wayne
you know and i know that you and i have
both been accused of being sellouts
yeah yeah a sellout is one
who will compromise their own personal
standards
personal convictions for the sake of
advancement
promotion or financial gain and so what
you're doing is you're selling yourself
out when you sell out you're selling
yourself up your own moral stands more
convictions here's this woman
that called him a racist she cited
herself
she was lying though because the the
dates
the time frame the chronology didn't
line up but she cited herself as a
victim of his racist
policies she also called him
a sexual predator and then she turns
around
he offers her a position and all of a
sudden she
all of that all those accusations went
out the door that's what you call a
sellout
right now to me she's the number one
sellout in the united states of america
and maybe on the face of the planet
earth you know what and i'm glad and i'm
glad you said that because i
you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of that
going around
on politics side you go along to get
along
as long as you are in the limelight as
long as your name is on
on the billboard you're fine with it you
know and
and to watch her pastor scott with
um when you look at some of their
followers or some of their supporters
oh no no actually the people that aren't
moving toward that side
don't you agree that they have to be
looking at her and be like
woman you only there because you're a
black woman and he told you that
and you are gonna just okay i'll take it
i'm looking for a black woman choose me
choose me
you're like the kid in class waving his
hand hoping the teacher calls on him
and once again rather than you
standing by your uh previous political
um uh accusations or statements
and saying uh i wouldn't care i don't
care if he's looking for a black woman
or not he can't choose me because the
guys are racist and a sexual predator
you know she she doesn't she she hasn't
done that i mean
that's like me saying biting sucks and
then biting calls me and offers me a
spot on this campaign
right and i go running man i'm not doing
that man i said he sucked so and i meant
it when i said it
and there's nothing to change my opinion
now and so
you know that's the thing that kills me
about it and how everybody is giving her
a pass
and by extension giving this guy a pass
as well you know it's like
we've lowered the bar so much with joe
biden that he's allowed to
have gaps he's allowed to have brain
farts he's allowed
to to say some stupid stuff he's allowed
to say
the reason he was able to survive in the
basement because some black women was at
the supermarket
uh stocking the shelves he's allowed to
say that because
you know he's joel
no i don't understand the democratic the
left-wing media has become the
propaganda arm for the democratic party
their modern-day
joseph gibbles with with adolf hitler
i agree let me um let me
i got a i got a couple of examples of
this um thing going on there's not a day
gone by that i haven't thought of every
american family that's lost a loved one
and i want all of you to know that
you'll always be in our hearts
and in our prayers but when you say what
the american people have done
over these last eight months hasn't
worked that's a great disservice
to the sacrifices the american people
have made
the reality if i may if i may finish
that
the reality is dr fauci said everything
that he told the president in the oval
office the president told the american
people
now president trump i will tell you has
boundless confidence in the american
people and he always spoke with
confidence that we'd get through this
together
the difference here is president trump
and i trust the american people
to make choices in the best interest of
their health
let's talk about respecting the american
people you respect the american people
when you tell them the truth
you respect the american people when you
have the courage to be a leader
speaking of those things that you may
not want people to hear but they need to
hear so they can protect themselves
you know what for her to say that and
after
after what we've just talked about she
sided with his accusers
she she she um she basically caught him
a racist
just like he said she was she was a
victim of his racism and then she gonna
turn around to
to biden and says but people want the
truth
people don't i mean it it's like that's
the part calling the count of black
you're siding with somebody that has is
doing all this stuff to you and you've
called him out
and because he's giving you a vice
presidential
part you're going to excuse it but then
you want the other side
well y'all got to tell the truth that's
a double standard
the worst part is he had to step down
the first time he ran for president
because of his lies what plagiarism
yeah and you know what's funny then he
turns around she's like the american
public needs to know the truth
are you going to pack the supreme court
right
right do you oppose fracking yeah
are you a proponent of the green new
deal oh i thought the american public
deserved to know the truth
yeah yeah man you know what she's you
know
she she pretty much to me epitomizes
the democratic party she's worse than
joe biden
i'm being honest she's worse than joe
and i think she
she really believes that we're stupid
she looked in the camera last night and
said did you catch it when she said
now do you know the definition of debt
and then she later on said
i don't know if you guys know the
definition of what a bounty is
and then she decided to tell us the
definition of a bounty
like all of america is stupid she's
ignoring the fact
that that story that bounty narrative
has been
totally debunked by the me that's the
reason why the media isn't running with
it
because the media even the left-wing
media knows
that that story has no substance to it
nancy pelosi the entire democratic
congress
they all know it's some bull crap
that's why they let it die in the water
and she's trying to resurrect that same
old tired lot
she's you know and the democratic party
is the lyingest
deceptive party on that i've ever i've
never seen anything like this in my life
well i mean i couldn't know they have no
moral they have no moral compass at all
right i mean look i've said many times
the oldest political party and the
dirtiest
the cheapness
group political group that this country
has had again the one thing i will give
them though
you know snakes stick together oh yeah
yeah
parties stick together like they stick
together whatever differences they have
they have their differences in private
they don't have their differences in
public
they stick together and i'll give them
that and
that's one thing trump said they rallied
around their candidate this same party
that didn't back kamala is back in
kamala now you don't have
some never kamalas over there and you
don't have some anti-buying
democrats and and democrats against
buying the republican party they need to
come up with that stuff we're splintered
and fractured
with that nonsense and and that's the
part that really really aggravates me
that these idiots on our side a number
of idiots on our side have defected over
to the other side for
what if you think it's bad now under
trump just imagine what it's going to be
like
under joe biden he got some dummies out
here i don't even
understand how stupid you are you hate
trump that much
that you're going to subject yourself to
democratic rule and reign oh man
my god you are some sellouts too there
are some sellers
american people have witnessed what is
the greatest
failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our
country
and here are the facts 210 000 dead
people in our country
in just the last several months over
seven million people who have contracted
this disease
one in five businesses closed and they
knew
what was happening and they didn't tell
you
our nation has gone through a very
challenging time this year
but i want the american people to know
that from the very
first day president donald trump has put
the health of america first
and quite frankly when i look at their
plan that talks about
advancing testing creating new ppe
developing a vaccine
it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
whatever the vice president is claiming
the administration has done
clearly it hasn't worked and you know
the vice president is the head of the
task force
and knew on january 28th how serious
this was and then
thanks to bob woodward we learned that
they knew about it
and then when that was exposed the vice
president said when asked well why
didn't you all tell anybody
he said because the president wanted
people to remain
calm well
so i want to ask the american people how
calm were you when you were panicked
about where you're going to get your
next roll of toilet paper
how calm were you when your kids were
sent home from school and you didn't
know when they could go back
how come thank you thank you when your
children couldn't see your parents
because you were afraid they could kill
them
it's that emotional thing man is that i
mean it's that
that's what they do she sounds she
sounded dumb right there
with that fake look looking into the
camera how calm are you
i couldn't find any toilet paper how
come with you
yeah i'm done somebody want to hear that
stuff
anybody knows let me tell you something
if i found out there was a fire in my
church while my congregation was going
on on sunday morning
i would try to uh contain and minimize
the risk without
running out their fire and everybody
jump up and start running at the same
time
now she sounds crazy and one thing i
always said you i don't care what
anybody says those coping numbers
those books have been cooked i don't
care what anybody says dying with covet
and dying from covet
are two entirely different dynamics all
of a sudden nobody's dying from the flu
anymore
all of a sudden nobody's catching the
cold anymore now we're like
it's double or nothing it's colder than
nothing so i don't want to hear that
stuff
she's crazy she's she you know what she
was backing herself
into a corner and she caught it and i
wish
pence had a caught it right and it's
when she began to talk about our
relation with
china and she was talking about our
relations with china in lieu of us
losing jobs and she said china won
and that's you almost she caught herself
she stopped how did china win
but how did china win this economic
battle by
sending covet over here in china one is
because they unleashed that doggone
virus
on the western world and she found
herself backing herself into that corner
and she stopped you know what pence's
over four million people have voted
people are in charge if they think trump
interrupt they better not put me up
there whether i
killed her and they've been calling me a
sexist and a misogynist and everything
else
i don't care you know why there's a
difference between being treated equal
to
and being treated same as now you have
to ask yourself
what do you want do you want to be
treated equal to
or do you want to be treated same as and
what happens is
people like myself and trump i treat you
same as and you start wanting to retreat
i'll give an example
i was on a uh the day the platinum plan
came out they had me do an interview
with these black democrats
it's me against four of them and the
black
now i've been working on the platinum
plan with president trump for over a
year
with jared kushner and others it rolled
out that friday
about four o'clock by eight o'clock i'm
on there with these other black
democrats and they're gonna know more
about it than me
they just heard about it four years ago
four hours ago i've been working on it
for a year but they're gonna know about
it more than me
so the girl gets on there the black girl
of course and she starts talking and
talking and talking and talking and
we go back and forth and when i
interrupt her and it came kind of hard
on it she tried to play the woman card
oh you don't respect woman i told him
come on here with that crap with me
don't don't try i said don't try to come
aggressive and then when i'm aggressive
back
you retreat into womanhood we're not
going to have that now
you want to be treated equal to or you
want to be treated same as
because equal to is where you don't tell
a woman
if i tell a woman to shut up i'm a
misogynist if i tell a man to shut up
it's no big deal right but if i tell a
woman to shut up i'm wrong now
even either this playing field is equal
and we're here as equal
combatants or where if i treat you the
same as i treat a man
you got a problem with it so you really
don't want genuine equality
you want to have your cake and eat it
too you want to be able to be aggressive
but i can't be aggressive back you want
to be insulting the pens
but pence can't be insulting back and so
that's the that's the
that's the way the democrats endeavor to
play it all the time
and that's why they don't like trump
because trump treats everybody equal to
i mean excuse me he treats everybody
same ass
yeah and so four million people have
voted
people are in the process of voting
right now
and so joe has been very clear as the
american people are
let the american people fill that seat
in the white house
and then we'll fill that seat on the
united states supreme court and to your
point susan that
the issues before us couldn't be more
serious there's the issue of choice
and i will always fight for a woman's
right to make a decision about her
own body it should be her decision and
not that of donald trump
and the vice president michael pence i i
couldn't be more proud to serve as vice
president to a president who stands
without apology for the sanctity of
human life
i'm pro-life i i don't apologize for it
senator harrison
susan are voting right now they'd like
to know if you and joe biden are going
to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
let's talk about that you once again
gave a non-answer joe biden gave
anonymous trying to answer you american
people deserve a straight answer
and if you haven't figured it out yet
the straight answer is they are going to
pack the supreme court
if they somehow win this election we
will not let anyone subvert
our democracy with what donald trump has
been doing as he did on the debate stage
last week
when again in front of 70 million people
he openly attempted to suppress
the vote joe biden on that stage said
hey
just please vote so i'll repeat what joe
said please vote
and we have a free and fair election we
know we're going to have confidence in
it
and i believe in all my heart that
president donald trump's going to be
reelected for four more years
here's the thing she like you said
she got back to the corner she got back
to the corner many times last night
where she didn't know
really how to respond so
there were there were many there were a
few times that she would say
i'm speaking when she said i'm
i'm speaking she's she's trying to work
in her head exactly what she's going to
say next she's trying to take a quick
break to understand
how she's going to respond she's trying
to channel hillary
i watched her and and whenever she
slowed down
like just a while ago and what
we have to do you know so like that
she's trying to work in her head how am
i going to respond to this thing
she wasn't ready she wasn't she didn't
have facts
i asked about packing supreme court
let's talk about packing
okay let's talk about are you going to
pack the supreme court or not
and it's and no answer right right she
didn't answer any of the questions
i don't think she answered one question
directly
she didn't same way joe biden did in the
previous week right
but yet they let him get away with it
yeah
it's an uneven playing field and it's
it's horrible
and she's a horrible lying candidate
right there and um i think the american
public should be able to see right
right you know right through her i think
it speaks volumes she tries to play
emotions
and she talks about toilet paper when
real emotion is he had pence had caleb
mueller's parents in the audience that
was important
to show that the obama administration
did not save her
and they could have helped her and the
parents will even admit to that too
if you want to talk emotion that's
emotional not talking about toilet paper
i'm sorry just isn't yeah
so you know that that is what it is and
once again then they go right into their
spin
the liberal left-wing media tries to act
like she did some phenomenal job and she
um hit the ball out the park and
everything and she was horrible she was
she had a very bad performance there she
was
um obviously flustered on a number of
occasions
and so whenever she would get very
flustered she would go into her antics
it's the body language now it's the it's
the head shake it's the hissy pain it's
the uh uh
it's the eye roll it's all that she did
everything but smack her lips and do her
neck like this she did most of the
stereotypical
once again diary of a mad black woman
antics and so
and i'm not surprised um and then the
very next morning they try to change the
rules
of the debate for the next one i don't
blame the president for saying
i'm not i'm not going to be a party to
that yeah he said he said he was going
to
do a a a rally or
or or not him his campaign manager said
that
they'll probably do a rally in instead
um of that i you know i i i
honestly you know if that's if that's
what he wants to do
uh but i just two hours ago joe
responded to that
i did yeah and he said you never know
what's going to come out of his mouth
talking about trump joe is the one you
never know was going to come out of
somebody's mouth right
no actually actually you do incoherent
gibberish racist incoherent
listen i understand that you know why
would i debate
you just like right now we're on camera
with each other
but we don't know what's going on often
right
and for what you know you can have
somebody with a teleprompter right there
or a monitor right there typing answers
to questions in real time for joe biden
there's too much that can be going on
there's too much deception
and and and fraud that can be going on
with telling that that's not a debate
and so
let's not even try to act like that is
debates you know the
the seminal debate of our generation of
my generation was richard nixon
john f kennedy in um
1960 and what
nixon lost that debate because of body
language
because of the sweat that was coming
down his face and the cameras
focused in on his hands during the
debate and so there's a lot more to a
debate
than than simply the words that come out
of someone's mouth
i agree and so um the president is smart
he understands that he understands media
very much
he's saying one thing and wayne you were
there when he said it and i agree with
it and i find this out more and more and
more
he said the left-wing media was human
scum
and and and every day i realized that
more
and more and more and more and more yeah
it's a shame the american public is
being done a great disservice
uh through the left-wing media they
haven't learned since 2008 or
and it and it's like they don't they
even tried to learn
they they're still playing with the 2016
playbook
yeah you know they they they weren't
able to derail
the trump presidency they've been mad
that the american people chose president
trump and didn't follow
who they wanted and they've been trying
to get back at
each one of us for the last three and a
half years
and now they put up this
78 when they said that biden was going
to be 78 years old
i'm white oh my god i i mean
i remember reagan but reagan wasn't 78
when he got elected he won 78 but
everybody was talking about reagan's age
brian's gonna be 78 if he wins
i'm like but y'all talk about uh old
white
gop and old white republican stuff and
then y'all gonna elect
joe biden and he doesn't even have all
of his faculties
you're absolutely right and you know
once again my
disappointment is more so with the
people here on the right
both black and white that
are willing to overlook all of joe
biden's obvious flaws
because trump hasn't danced the way they
wanted him to dance
right and it's disheartening and it's
it's
um very
frustrating to watch those that are
called they're rhinos the republicans
are name only and they're
jumping to that party but you don't see
the democratic party
breaking ranks like that they settle
their differences behind
the scenes and you know one thing about
and i have to say this
you know and and i said it about blacks
on the left but i'm saying it about
blacks on the right now
and i put it on facebook on twitter the
other day i was sending to a guy
you know what i'm tired of i'm tired of
black folks
whining man it's like black america all
the black community does
is why why why why why and the blacks on
the right are whining as much as the
blacks on the left wine
stop all this wine and equipment and do
something
on your own of course why do you want
somebody to give you something
and get it for yourself james brown
after james brown in the 60s when james
brown put out that similar black anthem
say it loud i'm black and i'm proud
you know what this follow-up record was
to that way i don't want nobody to give
me nothing
open up the door i get it myself and
that's the mindset that that my
generation had
right but this this this modern
generation of blacks on the left and
right all they want is somebody to give
them give me give me give me
give me give me give me what's trump
going to give us what's brighton going
to give us
who going to give us something everybody
gave us nothing we give me give me give
me
get it yourself
get it yourself and so what happens is
we have too many people on our side
breaking ranks
to go to summit and you know what's sad
here's the sad part
the demands that black conservatives are
making on donald trump they're not gonna
make those same demands
on biden sit there and shut up
and for the next four years just hope we
get another republican in office in four
years
inviting wins [ __ ] no they're gonna hide
set
one stew yeah
why don't i hear the black community
left and right saying
what is going to do for black people
what is going to do for black people why
aren't we hearing that
why are we hearing what did brighton say
about black immediate controls at all
black people yeah but media doesn't
control social media
yeah the media the left-wing media
doesn't control and they quiet on social
media
the blacks on the right are quiet about
social media
they're quite on social media about joe
biden's
disparaging comments and attitude
towards black america
that's very shock like why why are they
so quiet
you would think they're more vocal about
trump than they are about biting
well and body done pissed in our face a
thousand times
yeah and he's gonna do it again he's
gonna do it again
i've seen many i've seen many um
stew and sit and and and challenge trump
and
and and beg people for money in the same
sentence
yeah you know i mean like like they're
doing something
but they're like well trump doing it and
trump doing that and i'm talking about
some black conservatives now yeah
i know trump doing that and uh
but uh i'm selling t-shirts so
y'all go ahead and i know what to do
though i need to do so just buy me a
t-shirt
so bye-bye yeah
i've seen it i don't i don't get it i've
seen it you stay on
the ship and and and the bible says the
man's gift
will make room for him and bring him
before kings
if you haven't had room made for you and
you have been brought before
kings then you must not have a gift you
know you think you don't deserve
something just because you want it real
bad you don't deserve
access just because you want access real
uh to be able to speak into somebody's
ear just because you
want to be able to do it so bad your
gift needs to make room for you
yeah and you need to be saying something
that's worth
listening to you understand what i'm
saying let me tell you something
i've been pastoring my church for almost
27 years
i know what it is to have to leave
masses and everybody has a different
opinion on how you should do things
yeah and everybody thinks that their
opinion is the best opinion you've got
to filter
all this noise and try to make the right
decision that you think is right and you
don't need people
that because you know
you're not doing it the way they want
you to do it to say you're not doing it
right
but then as soon as you throw them a
bone they're okay
now that's the one thing that's the one
thing that disappoints me about
the right and the so-called conservative
platform
is that everybody is so selfish and
self-centered
that they're like if i don't get my way
and it didn't used to be like that
it didn't used to be like that i'm
telling you and back when i left the
democratic party in 2007
i looked at the conservative movement
not the republican move
well actually no no i did look at the
republicans i just didn't like
the outreach because there was because
there was no outreach there was not
i mean you know it's like hey you join
us and you
catch everything on your own you know
whatever but
i love the tea party and i love the
conservative outreach
well i love the conservative movement
because
things look like they wanted to move
stuff
forward and make a difference and the
conservative movement was
diff from was different from republicans
yeah but listen if there's no
outreach then instead of you whining
about not being in the outreach
you create some outreach yeah yeah i
mean
in 2017 when i went up to the white
house i didn't sit there and cry about
what they weren't doing and
what they weren't doing for black people
i put some stuff on the table
and i kept being adamant and forceful
inanimate possible until i got some of
the results that i was looking for
let me tell you something and i say this
very humbly if it had not been for
myself a queen linear there would have
been no criminal justice before
because originally there was none it was
prison reform
that was it there was no criminal
justice component i talked about it in
the book and i said hey man
y'all can't have criminal justice report
but i have a prison y'all can have
prison reform and i have a criminal
justice reform and i hammered it and
hammered it and hammered it and hammered
it and hammered it and hammered it
and screamed it loud and long until we
got criminal justice reform and i'm glad
to say i was able to contribute 27
pages of policy to it now you got to be
be what you're crying about rather than
cry about it
be about it and what's happening is the
conservatives on our side they want to
cry about it
and not be about it well if you think
there should be outreach
you let your voice be so loud that you
forced them into listening to you
i went up to the rnc i went up to the
rnc let me tell you something we wrote
walk down the halls of the rnc
myself kremlin there and at the time bob
tucci was the number two man
my first time over there we walked down
those halls of the rnc
you you've been over there before wayne
have you been in the rnc yeah you see
all the pictures on the walls right
yep you know what kareem looked at them
and said loud enough everybody room to
say here
he said man y'all need to get some black
people up on these walls
they're gonna get some black people up
on their walls in here why are there
only white people on these walls in here
yeah
do you understand what i'm saying people
you know what happens i'm gonna tell you
what happened
i blacked the services talking all that
smack outside but then they get in that
room
and get in that room with them white
folk and dummy up that's what happens
that's it they dummy up talk the same
smack
indoors the one thing i didn't do when i
went up there
i didn't put no tile
right the same slack i'm talking right
here on your show
is the same smack i talk about in the
oval office
i'm not changed my personality or
reduced myself
or limited my aggressiveness because of
the company that i'm in
and that's what people have to
understand you can't be one way in one
venue and getting another venue and then
then you chicken out
but if you don't have outreach then you
create the outreach and you make so much
noise that you force them to listen to
us or shut up
and quit lying on social media pastor
scott a lot of people in the audience
are saying thank you so much
for everything that you've done for us
they're saying and another person wanted
to ask what is the title of your book
nothing to lose unlikely allies in the
struggle
for a better black america
every time y'all have me on here i don't
let y'all talk
no wait we we plan for that we love to
listen to you
because that's why we have you on uh
that's why i do lightning rounds with
you i just randomly say things just so i
can get you to talk more our
folk better close ranks and stay on
board
and and and hold this dog on fourth down
and vote this man back in office is
y'all really gonna be whining you know
i'll give an example oh dumb
scaramucci has been ever since he got
fired
and first of all and i said in my book
scaramucci was never
that involved in the when i was involved
with the campaign in 2016
scaramucci was a gopher that's all he
was he wasn't
he wasn't a high level um strategist
with the campaign
but the thing about it is this now he's
talking about oh
i i think biden is going to win so i've
warned all my people
that do investments instead of preparing
for the stock market to dip
or stock market to go down okay how does
that
if you know the stock market is going to
go down and you're a guy that makes your
living off the stock market why would
you want right to win
yeah you still butt hurt because you got
fired
you know every time every time every
time that i do see him on
tv and watching him
in how he um slams president trump i'm
like
dude i mean you're just like all the
other wrestlers that
that that uh were angry because they
couldn't get what they want
or they got embarrassed publicly because
they weren't doing what they were
supposed to do
i mean look
and man mooch was never closer to trump
like that anyway
he portrayed that to the public he
didn't have that relationship with
with president trump he acted like he
actually on his twitter he'll say that
he was not friends with trump
and then he then then he'll say all this
terrible stuff yeah he pushed it
he he pushed it like he did but he
didn't and he did
and the guy gave him a job and he blew
it
you're so dumb you're so dumb you were
talking to reporters
on the record and and saying all this
stupid stuff and you thought they were
your friends
and man he gave you a chance and you
blew it and that's all it is
yeah um the book is nothing to lose here
y'all
nothing to lose it's a it's on amazon
right now
um oh wait we we gotta
we gotta we we gotta uh
well thank you we got a donation here
name
uh b with the b says i do not mind
people like you and others
who get the real stories out there about
the president the riots the pandemic the
lies
about donald j trump like being racist
i do not have time uh the leftist media
and and the leftists have the mainstream
media so thank you thank you be with me
you know what listen i appreciate you
guys having me on i have a one o'clock
appointment i have to be at
all right every time i come on with you
guys i have so much fun that time flies
and you guys are loud
y'all allow me to rant and everything
y'all allow me to rant like like i want
to rat so i
appreciate it and i wish i could spend
more time but i gotta go you though
i tried to catch you bro let me get in
let me get in let me get in but no
no no no let me wrap and i appreciate it
i appreciate it no
god bless y'all i love y'all and we're
gonna win
votes all right we got less than a month
to go we're gonna pull this thing out
you got it you got it that's it thank
you doc um
that's my uncle professor he's great
i love listening to him i can listen to
him all day
he needs to tour the country once trump
gets back in he just needs to go from
city to city state to state and just
fill up huge auditorium and just talk i
i needed to um i wanted to get this one
in too when you talk about accepting the
outcome of the election
i must tell you senator your party has
spent the last three and a half years
trying to overturn the results of the
last election
it's amazing when joe biden was vice
president of the united states
the fbi actually spied on president
trump and my campaign
i mean there were documents released
this week that the cia actually made a
referral
to the fbi documenting that those
allegations were coming from the hillary
clinton campaign and of course
we've all seen the avalanche with the
what what you put the country through
for for the better part of three
years until it was found that there was
no obstruction no collusion
case closed and then senator harris you
and your colleagues in the
in the congress tried to impeach the
president of the united states
over a phone call and now hillary
clinton has actually said to joe biden
that under in her words under no
circumstances should he concede the
election so
let me just say i think we're going to
win this election president trump and i
are fighting every day in courthouses to
prevent
joe biden and kamala harris from
changing the rules and creating this
universal mail-in voting that will
create a massive opportunity for voter
fraud
and we have a free and fair election we
know we're going to have confidence in
it
and i believe in all my heart the
president donald trump is going to be
re-elected for four more years
you know i've
you could hear her going she was making
these little sound effects because
she knew she got her gone oh yeah oh
yeah
and and watch um listen to him talking
about
sean showing resistance for the last
three and a half years
uh impeaching trump over a phone call uh
you know i'm like this is this is
this is well actually every
mostly everybody has a pulse has seen
this
what
they have been doing but it's i mean
it's crazy that democrats probably think
that so many people are following him
that that people are going to keep our
offices people are tired of resistance
people are tired of you
not giving president trump his due
especially when it comes down to
okay when it comes down to his foreign
policy
and everything that he's been able to do
um with the employment before covet
the tax the the tax cuts y'all can't
tell me that y'all didn't get nothing
from tax cuts you can't
you can't tell me that you didn't get
nothing from tax cuts if you didn't get
nothing you must owe the irs something
if you didn't get nothing okay
and uh where where pence said well you
know
uh that uh they are going to raise taxes
on you and and
come on no we're only going to raise
people 400 400 000 above
no you're gonna raise uh taxes on
everybody when you get
a tax cut that's that's exactly right
wayne
a hundred percent and that's including
the child tax
return too so you're not going to get a
thousand dollars per child anymore
you're right it's going to hurt everyone
and during that
uh clip that you just showed they were
talking about uh i think the question
was about peaceful transfer of power
which i find very frustrating because if
you remember on that cold day in january
when donald trump stood up there and
accepted and told everybody you remember
wayne you always talk about how he was
fighting for us
against all the dirty people uh that
were behind him
when when he became president little did
he know that there was not a peaceful
transfer
transfer of power to him if they made
them optically like the democrats do
it looked like there was peaceful
transition but really obama and hillary
were in the background spying on his
campaign trying to
wreck it there has been no peaceful uh
trans
you know going through even with trump
at this point
there hasn't been anything not fair no
you're right trump
trump trump didn't have a peaceful
transition
uh with all the things that pence was
talking about last night
and kamala didn't even come back and say
that he was wrong you notice that right
oh yeah she doesn't she didn't come back
and say no you lied she knows
she didn't no she didn't she let it go
we've spent 2.5 trillion dollars over
the term
in office my term that's over three and
a half years two point think of that 2.5
trillion i took over a depleted military
old equipment broken equipment even in
the army all brand new uniforms with the
belt everybody wanted the belt
but we spent 2.5 trillion dollars
we got everybody pay increases three of
them
there's never seen anything like what
i've done for the military
as far as the va is concerned what we've
done there with
choice and accountability
the va would be treating people badly we
couldn't do anything about the people
that were treating
our great soldiers our great heroes
badly now you fire them right away
because of accountability
for 45 years they were trying to get
that for more than 45 years they were
trying to get choice obama gave you a
weak version that didn't work it was a
joke
i gave you the mission act which is
phenomenal and it's worked out
fantastically well
and we now had a 91 approval rating from
the
vets our great vets our great heroes so
i just want to tell you
we have your back our military has never
been stronger it's never been better
we've never had equipment like we have
right now we have brand new
tanks and planes f-35s all of the best
of everything
nobody thought it was possible i just
want to thank a lot of the republican
senators because
getting it from the democrats is like
pulling teeth but the republican senate
senator imhoff and so many others
they've been fantastic
so i just want to thank them very much
but our military has never been in
stronger shape
whether it's a rockets or missiles or
anything you can name
we're building a lot of looks like we're
having a couple issues there
okay but um there we go so
obama depleted our military and she says
last night well
trump hasn't done a good job with
keeping america safe
she said something to that like and i'm
like he obama completed the military and
trump brought back our troops
how she just kind of made up stuff and
they said she made up a line
about abraham lincoln that she misquoted
him and made up a line that he didn't
even say
yeah another lie yeah she
she did she did everything and looking
at the
looking at the titles and i'm we we
we aren't dumb we knew what the
headlines were going to be we knew what
uh
george what george stephanopoulos was
going to oh yeah
do want to get to more on that i do
though want to bring in uh dr jen ashton
because it was all over social media
during the debate a lot of people
noticing that mike pence appeared to
have some kind of pink guy
what did you notice well george you're
not going to be surprised to hear me say
this but of course no one can make any
diagnosis
over tv but what do we know about ocular
or eye manifestations and kovid
it has been reported even though it's
limited in the medical literature that
anywhere from 11 to 30 percent of covet
positive patients
can have pink eye it can be an early
sign but george
he also could have just had some makeup
in his eye right
okay makeup in his eye
yeah i mean big conversation of the day
didn't i tell you i mean
nothing about pro-america didn't you
talk about how
pence is saving america trump and puns
are saving america no we're going to
talk about his red eye
his red eye and a fly his red eye
instead of and and and cover up and and
then
just pull out bits and pieces
about kamala harris and uh let me speak
can i speak thank you so much mr vice
president can i speak
it's my turn to speak honestly student
councils have better headlines
on the high school debate from the night
before than what any
media had today and just like a breaking
news president trump is to
host the rush limbaugh show tomorrow as
a virtual
mega rally and he's going to take phone
calls
that interesting there you go all right
um
we're getting ready to roll up out of
here i want to thank everybody for
tuning in to the show
thank you thank you pastor scott for
joining us
uh we're going to be as you know we
don't
um broadcast on friday so
this is the last show that you have for
us for the week i want to give a shout
out to all of our patreon members our
new members william melanie
johnny eleanor jemima terry laura
rich renee valerie nassar stephen patty
ricky kareem brian irene drew and karen
are our new patreon members as a matter
of fact
we got we had one last night too but
i wasn't able to put her on but um i
i won't let you know we haven't
forgotten you either i just didn't put
you on
um
i might be able to pull it up real quick
uh susan
okay susan thank you i will be adding
you to the list
i wonder if it was susan page the
moderator dalet no i'm just kidding
yeah right there and here are
more of our patreon members you can you
can become a patreon member
and help us take care of our bills
uh meaning that on the platform and
uh the the app for the show uh
and and the website itself that's where
your money goes and also
um um for the co-host too
so all you gotta do is just go to
patreon.comwd show
and from there you can decide what you
would like to do
again if you voted for trump
and you're trying to help spread the
message this is a great way
and helping the show because it helps us
travel get out the podcast things like
that so make sure you go there and check
it out
here we go all right ladies and
gentlemen y'all have a
great weekend don't do anything we
wouldn't do
and um it's supposed to be cool this
weekend so everybody um
kind of tighten up a little bit watch
yourselves if you are a mass
uh be respectful if you don't wear a
mask
be respectful both sides please
and with that said y'all have a great
[Music]
weekend